this podcast is brought to you by blue
apron the shows presented by on it this
podcast is brought
by blue apron blue apron is the number
one fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country
they're amazing I just got my dad I got
him a whole new kitchen set up so he can
try it
he's really excited I love it he loves
it you're gonna love it go to blue apron
calm right now slash Joey and you're
gonna get your first three meals for
free with free shipping that's blue
apron calm slash Joey the show is also
brought to you by lift go to lift calm
slash Joey today and sign up to drive
for lift lift drivers can make up to
thirty five dollars an hour and getting
started is just a tap away sign up today
at live.com slash Joey and when you
complete a hundred rides in 30 days
you're gonna get a 500 driver five
hundred dollar driver bonus that's
live.com slash Joey oh [ __ ] get your
Monday start
you
jesus [ __ ] christ jesus [ __ ]
christ two joints and some jungle boogie
who's better than [ __ ] you on a
Monday morning uncle Joey here my main
man if I'm hanging on the wall a badass
[ __ ] comedian from the store I look
at and I go Jesus Christ he's a savage
some nights he's got long hair sometimes
he's got a hat on I don't know what the
[ __ ] he is and I got my main man Lisa
yeah how was your weekend dog ah you I
had dams last night I actually went out
and was like an actual human being last
night I went to someone's house when we
went to Vicky's peasant we grilled tabs
are there they have to happens now you
don't have to have like the whole rig
they just have like the part they use
that you smoke it through and they hit
they have the torch those those are fun
I don't know why I don't know I don't
know why either I don't even know why
the [ __ ] I asked you anyway they're fun
with the eyebrows go on fine you spit in
[ __ ] blood no one does not burn my
eyebrows off as you you always have the
lighter on like the highest setting I
don't know how you like Jerry rigged
your lighters I've never seen like
there's only [ __ ] like light is this
provide a lot of fun I'm saying those
little [ __ ] lines butane ones yeah
yeah I know exactly how to juice those
things up like a minibike
no he doesn't have a butane one he has a
regular ones here I got the regular once
they get low I got these [ __ ]
that's a low one right there but this is
my travel one in case the plane goes
down boom I got a little lie there is
[ __ ] you always gonna have like a play
by there [ __ ] guy what's a Zippo oh
yeah at once where you can you know the
top flips up too much drama five all
high school just to do all the trick
yeah yeah and I would you too it was
like so nerdy
just don't like YouTube had a flip on
their own you know I think it's a pain
in the ass I gotta take a tool once a
week and fill it up yeah
God knows who's smoking around me next
thing you know when I Barton was blowing
up just give me the [ __ ] blue lighter
there $0.99 yeah but it's kind of cool
that once you just spark it it's on you
don't have to hold the thing round you
know it's classic it's got advantages
and listen when I get a blowtorch
I got a blowtorch in my trunk and it's
you know I don't know I just like these
little things so you get rid of them you
throw more those are the gold standard
other so he said
I don't want to you know people get mad
at me you need to use a string when you
smoke when I won't leave me alone I
don't have what kind of guy I have or
leave me the [ __ ] alone I'm just trying
to put the pieces together smoke dope I
gave up edibles for Lent
that's it you know listen guys there's
no reason why I should be opening up a
show with 1500 milligrams of THC every
day that's just [ __ ] animalistic type
[ __ ] I came to terms with myself about
ten days ago what am i doing I went home
one night and they think [ __ ] another
three stars I had in the desk I want to
climb I could even go to sleep
wait it was going through my mind you
went home from a podcast and eight more
stars I was eight I it so I blast it's
600 more milligrams like 20 100
milligrams the next one that woke up I
couldn't do nothing all day I was anyway
got my kidneys hurt you [ __ ] my
gallbladder hurts I'm like this has to
stop this has to stop I gotta switch the
pills I got do something my god oh my
god a Puerto Rican [ __ ] farm it's
just to hook me up with something just
it's a [ __ ] nightmare you want line
yeah you get bills online did you know
that yeah oh yeah I'm from Canada and it
tastes like a week what you don't need a
prescription or anything they just send
you whatever no they send me whatever I
haven't done it but I heard like
whenever I go to look those porn sites
they have ads for it like the generic
cialis you can buy it for like ten cents
a pill I think it's just Canadian
pharmacies and they just somehow I mean
how do you know you're not getting
[ __ ] no it's a low milligram they got
your address next thing they'll send you
a [ __ ] bomb I don't need this [ __ ] in
my life yeah what happened to the
[ __ ] do it in the corner shake it
like a brick and mortar yeah yeah listen
that's why they haven't for years I held
on the medical marijuana license they
started making good atoms uh-huh because
I always thought that took the suspense
out of it the whole suspense is going
with dealers house and being all creepy
and don't that you're going or hiding
anything that you know the ritual
driving a home and stop it and get a
6-pack and rolling papers and light as
an ice cream you know you're walking
into a store but now what the [ __ ] now
at your doorstep dealing now it's at
your [ __ ] doorstep so but that's a
type a little bit of that patois off
them making your heart beat that's what
you do it to me
I had so what a [ __ ] Mouse what's in
your world talk to me what do I got I
don't know me and just you know stand up
see you out and about I've been doing
that and this special coming out trying
to promote that and audition every now
and then you know same things you grew
up in see oh yeah from Seattle High
School the whole [ __ ] thing yeah
elementary have we were alpha grunge I
was but island now isn't like the heyday
like before how old were you three nah
I'm born in 84 so really yeah so nine
knows not what was that part they would
go to Pearl Jam that big parts what what
they with the with the with the metal
tubes is [ __ ] what do you mean what if
this is a put post of all this like a
famous Pearl Jam poster or something
yeah and this blade went to that part I
brought I was on Seattle heavy yeah you
district yeah I went to University of
Washington no yeah yeah I used to rep
the paddleboats oh can I think oh yeah
I'm like Washington watch yeah you know
that's awesome that's awesome stop the
summer's Seafarer you see if a Seafarer
and I went to the [ __ ] place to watch
the concerts at that Gorge the going all
of the board is yes the gorge I didn't
well that [ __ ] up there was uh I was a
starving comic up that lived with a
stripper and like you well I didn't live
with it no I look at my parents it was a
little more we got straight-laced we got
the mean right Miran read yeah I
remember on the other guy what's the
Karl Karl woman Hogan I lived on the
beach see Beach was a chi e oh okay oh
man that's that's a dope place your home
time when there was Taco Tuesdays at the
corner at the biker bar and what about
that chicken teriyaki place you talked
about
yeah with Josh wolf there was just right
next to Swann his brother was a second
time still there now I don't know it's
been 20 years of the warrant it's a
[ __ ] I can't make it come back
in Seattle cuz that [ __ ] warm but you
know what man I think it's time to call
Greg powers and wind and get the warrant
[ __ ] I want to go visit Ivan salivary be
nice to go back up there and walk around
I was good that was a great little place
it was just one of those places for me
that it was just a bad it was the talent
of my bad luck days like it was the
talent like I went up there and there
was something to test in like comedy
uh-huh like to test my loyalty the
comedy like what brought you out there
so were you your East Coast dude before
that I was a Denver do now hold you're
doing comedy that one Boulder at the
time Here I am China there's different
types there's different types of level
of frustration in comedy you move to LA
you don't get spots your friends are
getting spots that's one frustration
yeah the frustration at the time for me
living in Boulder was there was no spots
yeah it doesn't seem like it was [ __ ]
brutal Monday nights was an Australian
bar eight people always drunks like uh
like that it wasn't really there one
Australians they were white people but
it was like the Outback type bomb right
you know they're Wednesday Tuesday was
the Comedy Works Wednesday it was Club
52 and Thursday's was that Mexican place
by Burbank was El Torito you know at 16
spots a month yeah that's not much
that's not much
and every once in a while they would say
yeah he were here last week and that's
not guaranteed the comedy works you know
the club's didn't really give you guests
that's on the weekends you know no I was
frustrated you know and I started going
on the road I went to Michigan I met a
girl and I went up to see how she was
moved to Seattle I had had enough a
[ __ ] Boulder I was going through a
divorce a thousand things I said let me
go up there
I'm telling up to Seattle and Mira I was
doing 25 sets a month yeah and getting
paid for half of them you know getting
on you're not always 75 hours when
you're fighting for your life those
things help you know they really [ __ ]
help you but how was the scene before
you left what have you been in Los
Angeles then I came in 2012 I think
you've done a lot of things right guy
cold yeah here and there you have got
some things like I mean stand-up I've
been doing forever I like even doing
that 14 years and then but when you come
to LA you do other stuff too you'll
audition first often do you wanna or do
you just want to be a comedian
no I want it to like I wanted to do it
all
I love stand-up and I'm always gonna do
that and because the other stuff is so
fickle and fleeting like sometimes you
get something and then sometimes you
don't but you have a spot every night
you can count on that
and that's always gonna keep you
relevant even when you go through a dry
spell
people will see you to stand up and then
it puts you in the game for auditioning
for something I may be booked him a role
so that stuff is fun but I don't stand
up me too
when I got here it was funny how I came
here to be a stand-up but there was no
way I did just didn't want me but Mitzi
liked me but that's that that's the
sickest person that was the only person
you that was like you yeah that was it
that was always Mitzi liked me and she
gave me spots off the junk she didn't
like everybody she's notorious and
there's stories for passing on legends
yeah she was she she [ __ ] was a great
lady to me but that was it no montreal
nobody want to represent me for Tom me I
was too dirty it was like a [ __ ]
struggle you know like a struggle
sometimes even going on but uh you're
right you keep progressing down here you
when I got down here man understand them
you don't wanna and what do you mean I
go out every night is now you need to
him when he said commercials I was like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
I'll do that still sometimes I'll go off
commercial and a heartbeat yeah I would
go out for a come on now and this point
in my life I'm bragging really you stole
one do commercials I would do a
commercial now in a heartbeat but but
but you would want to be presented
they'd be like yo Joey want you to do
this then you would do that but you're
not gonna go to the cattle call at this
point you know I'm the type of guy like
they still do that like if you give me a
feeling with twenty other actors waiting
to go in and go in you see people you
haven't seen in you know the auditioning
game here was like my social life for a
while I can't lie me I had no social
ever did drugs right at night at the
Comedy Store after I got offstage
there's no social life you know you hang
out with a bunch of comics but it was
really weird when I tapped into the act
like I actually went to acting class I
went to Havana shopping I was serious
about it and it was very interesting
because I got to see a different taste I
got to learn how to hustle acting work
that's a whole other animal
all of atoms so I'm watching all these
guys that come out here you know they
just think them so someday I'm gonna be
an actress I don't really know what goes
into it they come out and they I would
go to that class and feel bad for half
the people I would want to go up to
local music go back and work for that
the same er you know of being a stand-up
comedian in an acting class is that
you're not was a good kind of jaded but
you have you're self-aware
they told I was a god yeah they thought
I was a god it was the weirdest [ __ ]
thing I would do the scenes and they
would clap because you have a natural
ability and you can but yeah this thing
cuz we go up every night and we have
that gear I mean they come up to me and
go haha you were stand-up I swear to god
they will come to account they start
with their boyfriends or sisters or
mothers and leave their with their jaws
drop
yeah my team ago a psychic Chris Rock
just what up yeah I don't get it
you're here Chris Rock like they would
look and it was uh like I I tapped into
that game and I'm like wait a second I'm
gonna attack this because these
[ __ ] are insane ones like yeah
like they just go to our dishes there's
got to be a different way and the beauty
is cuz we've got stand up stand picking
up a lot of our time and we have that
like when we go to class over to ever I
did it for like a month or two before I
ghost wasn't for me
but just observing some of the actors
they just drink the kool-aid like
anything the acting teacher says to do
they'll do it they'll make a vision
board they'll bust out the glue stick
and cut out magazine things thinking
they're gonna help them get rolled guys
it's crazy like kumbaya they'll do they
just want to book a role and will do
anything the teacher tells them to or as
a stand-up I'm like yeah I just want to
run some scenes I don't yeah I don't
want to [ __ ] glue some shipping on it
how [ __ ] boring was that one you get
together on Tuesdays with some kid yeah
that doesn't know dick about dick you
were asking like that for an hour
have you ever watched a movie do you
even know about beats and [ __ ] this is a
[ __ ] you know what what's always killed
me I don't want nobody at home to take
this wrong and don't take this wrong his
house you know what do you got acting
class and have coach
and they missed Vanka and she was under
what's-his-name but then some big black
[ __ ] got like Queen Latifah
dumps herself off and says let me give
this a whack yeah she starts making you
look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah because
look at Ice Cube you think you went to
acting class how much for Jennifer
Hudson Oscar yeah you know it's uh this
is it's you know I always felt when I
got here I'm the type of guy I want to
get formal training and everything if
you send me Joey I think you need this
I'll go hunt the best person yeah and
I'll figure out how well there's value
in it I will concede there's no there
was value but sometimes there's this
other side even believe in hope how do
you mean cultish it that you don't need
a vantage Chubbuck and the chickens on
La Brea are the cult's hmm she still
sends me [ __ ] emails you know I feel
like you know what I don't know but all
the same kind of rule and then they used
to be the one on fountain whether you
have to stood out stand that side oh
wait tell me that's still there I don't
go driven by one and there's many people
out there going over side yeah and you
never hear about those people like some
drunk guy losing control hitting them
with a car like never they're out there
man cause it do 100 and nobody's ever
hit those 18 [ __ ] idiots it's a
goddamn in you feel so because it's true
they do drink the cooler and you're
because they don't want to get out I
never figured out what it was
I had listened I decide you know that
one of my friends worked at CAA that me
and him walked into a vantage of it
together in 1999 we stayed friends till
about 2000 2001 maybe and then I'm James
Coburn and a stupid 100 I loved a movie
cause you quit acting class right I know
I was doing harmless [ __ ] and I had the
whole two days with him and I said do
you think acting class really awesome
because you have natural instincts quit
right now I'm like then your agents are
like all maybe you're not getting
auditions because you're not an acting
class so I went to the cult on labret
uh-huh she was checked pretty cute she
looks like Tina Fey
kind of sada she would always addition
with her socks on his [ __ ] her husband
would live in the mountains all China
sort of look like Tina feels this will
look like Tina Fey what the [ __ ] was her
name and she would run those kids
through the mill I mean it was like a
slave Factory
first of all you had to pay for your
classes and in turn it was like
Scientology I've always thought this
about outlet like no one's really
religious out here right but but there's
parallels like acting teachers are the
churches of LA and God is booking you're
right yeah yeah all right but people
drink the lemonade from they expensive
yeah yeah I never looked I haven't I
have a guy that I wanted to come on here
he helped me he helped me get analyze
that he told me to use my eyes more and
stuff because it's like it's like Phil
Jackson Phil Jackson was the worst
basketball player in the world
uh-huh he's a great coach yeah and with
18 championships there's that effect of
it he did an episode of cold case that
he was so bad on that episode yeah he
was the acting more like that they're
good at breaking news now oh yeah but he
was brilliant for anything he coached me
for analyzed that before I booked it for
the audition I went to New York and I
did I wrote down all his notes and he
booked me for something else I got and I
was like I like this guy then he got
sick for a while maybe he made a
comeback and now he runs something in
Hollywood like something better like
he's part of the Actors Studio thing but
it was always he teeth with the Hat with
the Apple hat uh-huh
and he had like six [ __ ] in
there that were taking everything who's
breathing class for $92 his movement
class come on we learned that at The
Comedy Store uh-huh you learned that at
The Comedy Store there's one day that
you're breathing your jokes and your
body language all become one it's a
[ __ ] great step yeah I've always
found stand-ups we're always trying to
the more you do stand-up the closer you
get to who you really are and acting is
the complete opposite of that they're
trying to be everybody but themselves
it's interesting it makes sense yeah it
makes sense
I just always I always heard rumors
Eddie Griffin causes a lot of havoc at
the store I love them Howard hears it I
wasn't there around that time but I hear
these stories and I love hearing about
the store he he would cause havoc but
let me there is a mighty Griffin man he
told you good comedic advice mmm tell me
what mangoes you'll never see us to have
a comic on a Harrison Ford movie why is
that you don't want him on the second
line was too good it was there's a lot
of actors that won't work opposite a
stand-up comic because the time is too
[ __ ] good our timing is deadly
and at the store your timing gets real
and the original oh I call the original
room the x-men training room the expert
there's no other club like it can't take
it away from it you could score me a
felon you call me a fat [ __ ] you know
did you call me a thousand don't you
ever saw my County [ __ ] because you
look down at that good yeah you know
that carpeting at the strong of his
senior there's a Rogen's dog took a [ __ ]
when the time really onstage the dog was
going crazy the cost of Rogen brought
the dog well it was like a Liza for a
little bit just bringing the dog all
this no no he would bring like everyone
so why he was single he was young uh-huh
he had this pitbull he said let me take
him for a ride and he put him in the car
but the dog would see his friends and
start barking get excited so one night
Rogen was me ah
Pauly Shore his friends and Joe and
there was like a Monday night it was
slow and jugglers hold on he wouldn't
stop barking he could hear Joe's voice
so Joe told what's-his-name bring the
dog up in the dog on on stage within
five minutes and took it [ __ ] the
original and I see you know Pauly's
friend was in there scrubbing it
in-between comedians [ __ ] you couldn't
write this stuff people have forgotten
completely about that I'm working up til
next time I seen him Frank God rest his
soul that was the name of the dog that
stage I died on that stage oh I have to
live a thousand times but it's great
it's therapeutic even doing you know
it's that's what exactly what it is
there's nothing like when we repeat this
constantly coming home from a weekend in
Charlotte we just this
you destroy it people are taking
pictures with you and you walk into
another original a little bit he go yeah
and all sudden the [ __ ] curtains for
me that drive home wasn't miserable
you're like what the [ __ ] was that about
yeah that'll happen you'll do like a
late night set or something and then the
next day they're just like five people
in the crowd I mean doesn't happen all
the time but it that's the beauty of
stand if this is very humbling you'll do
a great thing and then how long have you
been a regular at the store I got past
2010 so like seven seven years so when
you first got past with us busy as it is
no nah man it's like it's in the golden
age right now yeah it's in the golden
age and I got I got past you know when
Tommy was there and it wasn't it wasn't
like it is now it stays good pretty late
cuz you know goes till 2:00 a.m. at the
store house found good at night this is
fake good just what now how's the
midnight spots it's still pretty good
man I know she I remember when I would
get like midnight or later yeah it would
just be even 11:30 would be slim pickins
back in the day but now it's packed like
Rogen's bag your back and like like
Apatow comes my loot all these guys are
coming back these guys coming back so
it's packed every night now but yeah I
wasn't like that when I was going but
going down there how about this going
down there and waiting to get for people
to start this show and begging that
they'd stay so you get the company now
yeah begging please don't please I've
been here since [ __ ] 9:00 waiting for
a fallout just in case I mind something
I go home early cuz you'd have like oh
I've had like a one o'clock uh-huh let's
even give me one and I would have to
follow up Paul Mooney so I would be
sitting there late with coke in my
pocket dying to do a line dying to doing
wine but this [ __ ] won't put me
on the stage
and he'd be four people an interesting
story one night you know calmly used to
be Tuesday through Sunday
uh okay back in the day when I first
came out here Tuesday through Sunday so
if you went on the road you came home
Monday yeah and you left Monday night
into Tuesday morning you did Wednesday
radio Thursday radio oh sure yeah
so when I got here
was Tuesday what the [ __ ] was my point
she's crazy I gotta stop smoking pot if
the golden age' now it's a and but
during the week the store would have you
know four people Oh
Tuesdays when it was black night and
that's big name you'd have eight people
in the original home you'd be down the
road at a better measure a little more
Jay Davis song I always hear about
badgoblin dublin's wait and walk over
but Pete when he bought the last stop in
Houston said you know what Joey I don't
want to close Monday and Tuesday people
want to come in and drink what do you
think I should do - so just bring down
the headliner you know so for why he
started bringing down headliners I went
down there one Tuesday there's maybe 12
people you know man I wisdom into a
[ __ ] you know when there's 12 people
you're not gonna sit then do your
material yeah go with hoppin yeah baby
talk ask questions but I mixed those
lucky nights where I mixed everything up
together and it was it turns to be the
one of the best hours I ever did for 14
and a half beat happens and it's great
and Pete can watch me on the drive home
he goes I've been running this club for
three years
I'd never saw that he was most comics go
on stage and give up about six months
later Johnny Sanchez went down there was
another comic from the storage end that
we were working hard that it was made
child Luke Torres you know Pierre and
the same thing having a Tuesday and that
there was like nine people Johnny went
up there whip them up into a frenzy and
I'm I'm Pete calming going I know the
difference between the time they saw a
comic and a comic now cuz I just saw it
when you guys said because nobody else
comes in here on Tuesday everybody just
bounce everybody else sees nine playful
play they are like they don't want to do
it but we had to deal with that every
night going up you were just happy to
get a spot and those people are still in
those chairs so they they want to be
there so you think that if you go up
there with a bad attitude that of course
they're gonna be disengaged
so we've learned just like we love your
audience no matter who it is care for
four people yeah and I'd go up there
can put my life into it like I would
leave they go in Jesus Christ how ha
like I would in my mind I started
looking forward to empty rooms at the
store during I like that two men like I
like to do I just finished my special
and I'll all you're in hell right now
it's what I like getting late late night
spots of the store because there's
really no stakes it can be loose I can
run some ideas where if it's packed and
like I'm following Rogan or something
like I can't do the show it's a you just
trying to keep up here you gotta bring
out the a [ __ ] but when you're building
there there's nothing like like a half
filled or 1/3 filled bar and just having
fun trotting out ideas and I love that
it's not a bad idea there yeah so I kind
of right now I want the late-night spots
what what's worse is there difference
between like a a Comedy Store for people
or if like they're on the road and
there's four people out like well if
you're on the road we're at a point now
where if we do the road there's not
gonna be four people no one's hiring us
to come out to do four people right now
it's almost impossible for us to do bad
on the road at this point you know what
I mean right like do you ever I mean you
can have shows that aren't as good as
you know if it snows one night you're in
Buffalo nose mm [ __ ] of inches only
diehards are gonna come out but we'll
make the bet my mind I'll go crazy for
those 40 people yeah I can't pull [ __ ]
out of my ass I'm going to such that I
start drinking I don't drink but I'll
start drinking because they made the
effort so little [ __ ] my [ __ ] I
don't drink but tonight cuz you
[ __ ] here I'm buying you're
drinking I'm drinking with you you know
yeah those are things that they fire
yeah but they all go back to the comedy
store to that commando-style comedy I
learned at The Comedy Store that's all I
can call ya know stop cuz it's it's the
hardest room in the world and when we go
out and do somewhere else just a
fraction of what we learn in the o.r
goes so much further on the road yeah
I'm really lucky around that original
even now when I go in there like I said
I'm getting anxiety mm-hmm especially
now you look those lineups and you're
like Jesus Christ I can't even breathe
here you know you
daliyah yeah [ __ ] kidding me that's
like going through electric chair
another state I have to follow you
sometimes and that's I get anxiety over
that like well I should dance I mean
listen I go you but it's the same thing
though where you got because when the
comics were posted their lineups on
Instagram I'll see who I'm after and
I'll know just energy-wise kind of like
okay I can kind of like rest easy not
that they're I think they're good comics
but their energy matches yours hitting
the stage but if some like you're you're
like a bulldozer you're like a
juggernaut you just such a character you
know so and they're so amped up like
after you get off and I come up there
I'm like hey you come out like everybody
knows you like there's a shorthand when
people see you like I know this guy even
if they don't know you they know they
know you you know what I mean but when I
come from like hey what's up you know
they're feeling you out like what's this
guy about the reason why I go up there
was so much energy is because of my fear
because let me tell you something I'll
do for outdoor 40 minutes and 18 minutes
I'll just I'll [ __ ] your world up jack
yeah I'll just do all parts lights I'll
go up there just say one thing and just
laying to all the punchline I might
think that's all I love about the store
and you don't have to stop yeah you
could just laugh like I've been up with
the stroke I haven't taken a breath my
god just lay into him and look around
and they're scattered it's like The
Outlaw Josey Wales came in here I
remember the first time I took my dick
up not just on a Friday night
what the harsh if you're doing that for
a little bit like I would hear stories
we would do the craziest [ __ ] up there
but one night a Friday night I went up
there and something happened with Bobby
Lee and then something happened the girl
started yelling at Rogan and I wanna
update you start yelling they don't know
unless you're gonna [ __ ] come up here
and [ __ ] do something
whatever shut your mouth and she goes
what do you mean I know come up here and
show you [ __ ] and she goes I'll show my
[ __ ] if you show your dick get on up
here you little [ __ ] bat she went up
this lovely girl went up on stage and
pulled her pants down and showed her a
little ugly [ __ ] it was like somebody
hit her with a slingshot right the
[ __ ] place was packed
the outside went up to the glass like an
aquarium like an aquarium everybody was
looking so I Diaz Diaz it's Friday it's
a corner one the place is packed they
put the house lights on
I took the [ __ ] Cuban that grow out
people started throwing money at me like
80 through Laos that's more than you get
doing Stanley yeah yeah I got to close
with this more often
sometimes I did take my dick out and
just go up on stage and see how long it
would take before somebody knows the
best what I do to Judi Conchi alley
she'd go on stage and I go behind the
bar oh that back entrance to the and I'd
open up the curtain naked while she was
on stage she no no so she'd be getting
laughs and she get offstage go my god I
did so well tonight it wasn't her it was
that I was behind that completely they
give opening up the [ __ ] curtain
closing it it was you know but that was
then if every time a girlish don't put a
fart machine under the chest and we wait
for hosting to go on and he's tried
[ __ ] with the fart machine and the
homesman would lose his mind
whoo he's fine in here you know that's
that's what it's all about though that's
why you become a [ __ ] comic even 1095
you know see you go to the University of
Washington you're going to school you be
the good boy yeah all that you're
working at the salmon place someone's
saying I've heard no Pike Place bike
when I wasn't there I was just doing
school and comedy that's it then then I
graduated at the engineering degree got
out and then I got a job in uh I was
just applying to jobs in Southern
California
cuz I knew I wanted to be out here and
then do stand-up at night but I had to
get out here so then I got a job at
Boeing in Long Beach so they hired me
and I would uh I was doing like a stress
analysis on the planes you know and then
I would drive up at night and do
stand-up and then I would drive back do
work do it all over again for three and
a half years but I mean there's worse
jobs there's people oh no no no probably
cement like the cubicle I got to monitor
you think about yeah
close your eyes and put sunglasses on
that is [ __ ] crazy and one day and
what's your mom and dad think at this
time he just needed work I'm working
like they're not like they were cool
with me doing drama and like skits and
stuff in high school but then once they
could tell that I wanted to make a
career out of it then they got a little
nervous like even was in engineering
school and I was doing stand-up they're
still like worried that I was doing this
other thing you know and then I wanted
to do it and then when I was working at
Boeing I'm still doing stand-up and then
when I left
especially admit I'm leaving an
engineering job and they're like what do
you do insurance fool yeah yeah yeah all
that stuff all that stuff right they
lost their mind yeah because that's a
known entity that's a known quantity
being an engineer for X number of years
get a house get a car blah blah blah XYZ
with a regular life
stand up there's no path for that they
don't know anybody's kids who are doing
that there's no if you're a lawyer
there's a path if you're a doctor
there's a path stand up just seems like
a pipe dream but I'm close to it I know
that there is a way to do it it's just
too foreign to them you have brothers
and sisters I got a brother he's a
dentist
oh yeah I was making the [ __ ] I mean but
at least I feel like they're one for two
you know I mean like he did the he did
the good thing they're successful in
that regard he took the heat off by
being a dentist I think listen man I say
this [ __ ] constantly I say this
constantly and in the next five years or
the next two years is gonna be a report
to back my claim
you're not ready at 18 to make a
decision about your [ __ ] life man
yeah you're not [ __ ] ready at 18 to
make a decision about your [ __ ] life
man you're not really 18 to make a
decision about your life why do we
become parents and push our children to
[ __ ] make a decision at 18 or even 20
nobody in this room I know you're an
engineer I mean it's not anybody nobody
knows at 20 what the [ __ ] they really
want to do and then one day you raise
your [ __ ] hand and you're in there
two years and you go on TV and you see
some guy putting [ __ ] cigarettes up
his [ __ ] and you're like you know
what I dreamt that as a child I'm gonna
do that and now but now you're stuck now
you got a loan you got your mom proud of
you she cut the clips out you made it to
five bagger kappa you know and now you
graduate and now what bro yeah now
you're going to a job that you really
don't want to do you just want to put
cigarettes on your ass huh right that's
all you want to do with your [ __ ]
life man but no you get this job now
sponsor drinking now you mean a check
and you haven't you knocked her up and
you have a kid but guess what she's one
of those chicks that you're knocked up
let's say two tanks are in her ass now
now you gotta walk around with this
[ __ ] monster and that what a job you
hate with a kid who's uglier than you
are cuz now you got your wife it's a
[ __ ] nightmare you wake up one day
you're 38 you're like what the [ __ ] did
I do
and there's the path that starts
everything that's the drinking the drugs
the divorce you're unhappy you haven't
met not even a midlife crisis you don't
even want to do your [ __ ] job no more
man this isn't what you want to do in
the first place but you got yourself in
such a big [ __ ] hole with that fat
book and the kid and the [ __ ] house
with the lawn because America soldier is
America soldiers and you know I bought
it I bought it when I came out of prison
I'm like that's it I'm gonna be a good
boy and I'm gonna get a job and be a
roofing it's the middle of Saturday I'm
all the water and then a sudden I guess
I got the laundry and shovel and do
that's my life though I'm sixteen lines
then you give me a [ __ ] watch and and
this was the way I thought like I was
like that what am I supposed to tell
people I I went to college and wasted my
time
this is a waste of time they took me
$200,000 to really figure out what I
want to do in life which was put
cigarettes out my [ __ ] you know yeah
we are not we're not ready and let
everybody have you know who else is sat
in this chair what's the skinny girl
that was a doctor who was that Ashley oh
do I know actually yeah a skinny chick
she's the CA also opens up she's a
lawyer actually Barnham Callie [ __ ]
okay yeah that one who else was a
[ __ ] doctor I came in here something
like that and quit well somebody else
had come in here last couple of years
that were the doctors said that's it I
didn't want to do in the middle you know
it you you forced society forces you
then we drink it's a different type of
cocaine John wasn't here you go oh I'm
gonna leave my doctor patient to be
anything thank God it hit for him you
know when you take it even more
impressive
more impressive yeah that's the
residency and all then you have patients
and then they take that leap and I think
that's even harder your patients dying
he's not cheering for me
I'm dying over you you [ __ ] but
it's it's always that decision it killed
me
yeah I didn't know you think I want to
[ __ ] play that dumb [ __ ] if I would
have known this was it if I would have
known this was it when I was and I
started late dog I started 28 or
something that's [ __ ] late Jack I was
long in the tooth did everyone say to
you for him what are you doing with the
thing that my least favorite thing that
people say is a work isn't supposed to
be fun you're not supposed to have fun
at work and I like it just seems like
maybe an engineer in places like that's
what they would say comedies great but
there's but like works not supposed to
be fun well I didn't tell anybody at
work that I did stand-up just because I
like keeping my world set that's so
smart
yeah just and I don't want them to think
that I'm the funny like I'm
conversationally funny you know I'm not
off-the-wall I'm not gonna be doing
there's different types of comics you
know he's want to have a conversation
with somebody so I hate I would hate if
somebody at my job knew I did stand-up
and there's expecting jokes from me at
the copy machine or like a when can I
come see I don't I don't like that that
was good mood yeah I just know me I know
how people are so I just kept my wall
and I didn't want them to think that my
work was being affected by what I do
outside
of my job like I didn't want my bosses
to think comedy is affecting my work cuz
it's not and you were off on Saturdays
or Sundays yeah off on centers in
Sundays and then stand up as a night
game so you know I get off at all
weekends at that point like lawyerly nah
cuz that came later me getting past the
store came
yeah and came a little later call your
mama's got past this place I told you
these benchmarks for us don't mean
anything to my parents you know five is
[ __ ] they don't know the Comedy Store
names on the wall they don't know how
important that everyone TV yeah they
seem like some late-night sets and
they've seen me like I was in that Tina
Fey movie so like then went to the
theatres and saw that what they think I
think my mom is love I took my mom to
the premiere just you gotta take your
mom so I take she gotta meet Tina Fey
you know everybody like Margot Robbie
she was starstruck and she loved it um
but my dad is old-school like he still I
was talking along two days ago she was
like your dad's worried about you like
what are you gonna your life what are
you gonna do like I'm still [ __ ]
around here you know like my dad only
understands money and things what's your
bed he's an engineer Boeing as well
that's our coal mine man yeah bring me
dude
rainy dude yeah he's a smart guy he's
he's in Seattle he works at the the one
in Bellevue no that's what I figured he
knows what I can be so that's what
frustration shall be watching me stand
up at all you know what's so funny is my
dad loves Steve Martin this is favorite
comic but he just wants his kids to have
nothing to do with like afghans my
parent from afghanistan they don't want
they love art but they don't want their
kids to make a career out of it they
want them to be doctors lawyers and all
that stuff so yeah they consume art but
they're like we don't want you to do
that for a living
did your parents move from Afghanistan
yeah yeah I got like that ever since I
was like I can't I wasn't
first-generation or anything but I would
always get taught in like Hebrew school
and stuff like that like Jewish kids
like the Jewish families but that they
were it was huge when we first moved
here education all that like for those
like probably similar reasons while your
parents is just like they they're
working so hard
they see like that's the only real way
to guarantee I understand it oh yeah
like you know I've got my own path and
I'm trying to go down but I understand
where they're coming from yes just is
that immigrant mentality cuz I'm doing
what they weren't they couldn't afford
to do when you come from another place
you got to plant your roots yeah you got
it you're not gonna be a mime when you
come from Afghanistan and you're in
America you've got to be an engineer
you've got to be these things to just
plant your roots here and then their
kids me I can do calm mean I'm fortunate
enough to be able to do comedy but they
didn't have that luxury so that's why
it's so foreign for them I think I don't
know what my mom was saying she was
alive I don't know I really don't know
and I know it is grounded in them
wanting the best for me um cuz if it
pans out and it is it's on the road to
like I'm getting things and things are
going the right way they'll they'll be
if they'll be fine they'll stop nagging
my mom is cool and then you say my right
yeah yeah so just say then I got 401
yeah I've got but I think my dad just
wants me to pull up in in like a
Lamborghini and then he'll be like I was
wrong yeah well hopefully someday you'll
buy me a [ __ ] Lamborghini yeah did
your dad send you like that Boeing I
like the open jobs at Boeing in your
area
nah but sometimes he would still he
would send me articles and this is funny
I talked about on stage one time my dad
would send me he would clip out news
articles for some reason he doesn't
believe in emailing me a hyperlink to
the article so he physically cuts out
the news article sends me this piece
about this guy who's 30 - he went to
engineering school at u-dub and then he
opened up this brewery and then he
writes on a post-it note on the back he
goes maybe your classmate question mark
could be you if you woke up before knew
loved oh yeah this is so funny
like these don't understand it
it's a different type of work we work at
night and sometimes we have super early
audition sometimes we work for two weeks
sometimes we work it's just so sporadic
and almost just being available is part
of our job
yeah yeah you have to be available
because in their mind if I'm not working
all the time like why don't you just
sell houses on the side
it doesn't work that way I got to do
stand-up it's you being nimble as part
of the job description that's why all
these actors are waiters and waitresses
and bartenders so they could just cut
out and drop of a hat yeah what's the
safety I never believed it either well I
got hair so cigars on the phone
cigars were huge when I got here well
what's the name Demi Moore smoked us to
go on a cover of magazines oh yeah
you're right man
I remember there was this huge huge
women was smoking cigars at bars people
out the comi store smoking cigars so
they're right on the grand sunset right
on the street afterward towards the
comedy store there was blue office
12:59 plus Commission you sold those
three of our packages and they give you
80 bucks
I'd sell one of those a day maybe a
couple cigars go home
yeah I was dead selling the morning
though so I would snort coke till 5:00
it's a comedy store and I know that's
seven more like a soldier
yeah well always reduce on my breath and
Jen and God knows what else you got you
gotta have a little job here but once I
booked my first commercial I think I was
like that's it I'm taking the safety net
all that's it
yeah I made a living I'm good I used
engineering to get to a place where I
wanted to be so you know I had a day job
was fine most comics have a day job
they'll do lifts they'll do Ober they'll
do all these other things I just happen
to have a dope day job and then by night
I would do stand-up and then I got to a
point where I could leave and that that
was always the dream just get to the
have the safety net until I don't need
it when you quit your job you would tell
him to leave the door in case I did I
did like so what happened was I booked
this MTV show called disaster date which
is like this prank show for dating and
they needed me for three and a half
months and I was half steppin before
then like I would I booked Chuck on NBC
this guest star was the first thing I
ever got and I said I had
family emergency so I left for eight
days to film it and then I came back and
I just continued to work but three and a
half months was too long there was no
excuse for three and a half months I
forgot what I said but I said yeah I
need to take it off for some reason and
they wouldn't let me and I tried
everything and they just want to let me
take that much time off and then I read
up on unemployment that like if they
fire you you collect unemployment so I
didn't want to quit cuz then I wouldn't
be able to collect unemployment so I
wrote an email I go I will be out of the
office this day and I plan on return and
then I just wrote three and a half
months later I plan on returning this
day I send that off to everybody and
then I just didn't answer any of my
calls or emails and then just waiting
for them to fire me if they were so I
wanted to come back and if that isn't
the case they would have to fire me and
then they did send me a termination
letter and I was juiced I was like nice
Oh your dad must have been steve-o I
didn't tell them the nuances of the
termination whole thing right yeah yeah
no severance paying nothing no no a
stapler I probably took a mechanical
pencil did you ever do that Joey oh you
must not like not showing up back at a
job I did a lonely place every day that
was a Radio Shack I was terrible there I
had no like I just thought Radio Shack
you just sold like batteries and random
things they have like people coming in
who are building like circuit boards
when they want to really expect you to
know actual resistors and ohms and all
this have no idea what was happening it
was the only job I ever worked
commissioned and I think I made like 200
bucks in a week and I just didn't go
like they want me to drive 45 minutes to
do like training and I just didn't go
back you pick up your check yeah I won
back in that no that's one time I like
tried to work at Domino's and so I had
to go through some training and stuff I
did like three hours of training on a
computer how to make a pizza and [ __ ] it
was dumb some program some software I
did it for three hours and then I got
off work and then I ended up getting
some other job so I quickly
I literally just did the training and I
left and then the check was like four
five but or I was something stupid I
didn't even pick up the check so I
basically just when the dominoes to kick
it for three hours thunk I quit so many
jobs the day of what did they want
I forgot I quit this job there was a
manager trainee program Secaucus 45000
the start like just you know then they
wanted me to work clerical for three
months something else for three months
warehouse for three months at Mel's for
three months and then you become a
manager to the lumberyard yeah I did for
about 10 days does and it was until
fourth of July weekend with all my
friends with down the shore and I'm
sitting and I gotta sit till six and
there's not one customer on that line
they're making me couch grooves this
busy work file I just [ __ ] put
everything away got my carving I was
like where are you going I used I
wouldn't even say anything and those
days I wouldn't say anything
Halloween 84 I stayed out I'm like a
four [ __ ] day bender like I wanted on
Thursday to come back and I [ __ ] stay
down like just got [ __ ] up Thursday
night Friday night Saturday Sunday
Sunday night a friend of mine called and
she goes hey my dad got your job that's
his paints thought I was like a [ __ ]
full charged criminal by this point I
just give it up
I'm like some [ __ ] paint dog yeah
that's kind of nice how the job just
falls in your lap oh my god I just went
through like 4,000 cocaine that wasn't
mine they were gonna come looking for
any moment I told my be back in an hour
I never came back with their [ __ ] bag
of blow I ended up with this girl
bleeding from my nose she was bleeding
from her nose we tried to have sex and
then that I went back to wherever I was
living in those days and that's what my
friend walked me I'm gonna go say piss
called you dad that got you a job on
68th and burger line at this paint place
I walked in there I was like this is
gonna change my whole life like I'm a
new man I have to stop this this [ __ ]
half a gangster's looking for me now for
his [ __ ] four grand and it was a lot
more than four
right I wouldn't man they were like
though hey you never mix paints this
morning and I'm I'm gonna look like that
clock it was eight to nine was a long
now and nine to ten was even a longer
how but there was nothing like ten to
eleven it seemed my count awesome
resistance from the war of art started
to come up and [ __ ] and I just thought
I'd get negative thoughts or Wednesday
I'm getting damn box and I don't make
$80 three times five are you [ __ ]
kidding me I gave it all to blown make
seven now hello if we get telling them
listen I'll be back in five minutes and
they're like wait you gonna have a soda
across the street
you never had a gold watch and maybe
four hours had stolen this gold watch
somewhere it was like a nice bowl of are
like that 3000th our [ __ ] watch and I
ended up with it and this is my last ray
of hope after this and I'll never forget
that went into a drug dealers house I
knew like by just like like there was
least drug dealer I knocked on his door
he's like oh you I go I'm a good friend
the leaves on Joey Diaz he was come on
it I know listen man you don't know me
from Adam I'm gonna bind hey the half
ounce he your best coke I'll leave my
watch as a collateral be in an hour give
me the 800 he was like all right I took
that cook I never came back either that
was least a week from [ __ ] now I was
everybody was waiting for me it's
telling everybody lb back I'll be by
your alone give me five minutes
I just gotta hope the corner well pork
chop your head back
I used to quit jobs I would go to a job
to give me like a shovel ten minutes the
money here [ __ ] you I think come on it
is shovel ten minutes I would last ten
minutes
I built scaffolds for a long I got them
they're like are you scared of heights
I'm like man they're like 15 bucks an
hour all right after the third floor
yeah now I'll be right back I'll be
right back
then I went to the other side of the
building this is a huge building they
were building I took every job in the
[ __ ] building
the people who spray that [ __ ] on your
building so it's like a insulation oh
yeah I took that job too
that lasted like a day I picked up my
check then the people who put this the
railroad ties into the floor to build
the walls I did that for a while that I
liked except for the [ __ ] splinters
and the red ants bite me yeah it's not
that bad you're gonna work out in the
after you get a big drill what's the
matter you didn't even need a [ __ ]
edible I'm not I'm not I'm not to yell
when I'm making [ __ ] faces I'm going
through changes because I'm just
imagining you're going and just like
quitting a job every other how you get
these many jobs I mean I could sell a
[ __ ] ice cube to a [ __ ] Satanist
understand me I don't give a [ __ ] jack
you just give me a [ __ ] resume and
I'll [ __ ] type it up for you in no
time I'll get you that job
did they not call references back then
even if they did I didn't know what they
were so nice that's great references and
those do all your references sound
exactly like you oh my god I had such
faith like if I got fired from a job but
it was a good job I'd rather does a
reference then they would call me the
people gonna listen we just tried to
call the Sheridan and they said you were
fine I'm like warlocks I didn't get
fired
I just [ __ ] quit after a year and a
half well they said I would argue they
would say they couldn't get hold of
references I would make up names I was
[ __ ] the Tories for that [ __ ] because
in my mind I really didn't believe that
yeah but they check references we had an
undercover copy thought on the phone
today and he was talking about a gay he
had to meet this killer at a gas station
on time well in 85 I ran out of you know
I was [ __ ] out that I was crazy so
jersey in portland oregon are the only
states where you can't pump your own gas
oh I knew I knew that about Oregon
writing about Jersey - you can't pump
your own gas well I would get gas
station jobs close to the bridge of the
tunnel where there's a lot of action and
I would go in there what's your name
[ __ ] I'm walk and then go really what
do you want to work with chef 12 to 8
the moon I said I gotta check a
reference you know I was like I totally
I go leave you working with a gas
station of you Leona and you gotta fill
12 days Mike I'm gonna go 12 to 8 yeah
you're gonna hire me without even a
[ __ ] reference check and I would get
the job and I would fill up gas tanks
people come in give me 40 give me 50
wait for I get $3,000 let take off I
leave the gas station open the red
sister for the taking it was [ __ ]
crazy and I must have done it ten times
they never caught on I'd see a help want
inside the gas station
I do the application and they tell me
when do you want to start I go next
Tuesday night okay and I tell you like
let me borrow 200 the next Tuesday night
like I already had it down in my head I
was just going in there
pumping gas for four or five hours
keeping all the profits they would ask
you did you dump yet oh yeah I don't cuz
they'd make you make a deposit every
thousand dollars talk to you I dump like
a $10 bill in there I keep the rest I
put it my socks [ __ ] crazy
I had no respect for work that's why I
knew this didn't work I'd be dead yeah I
didn't want to work it was a little
[ __ ] way I think about it mountains
oh you got like a six of them old look
around go cuz they did it so it's nice
it's nice to be doing what you want to
do and every day it's not work it's a
cliche you always hear like oh you know
do it you love you don't work a day in
your life but it's true you wake up and
it's nice that everything that I do is
working towards something that we're
building not somebody else's thing but
sometimes you got to do that and when I
was at Boeing I did that because I knew
I was trying to get to this thing
it's alright to do that for a while but
to have a goal was Tony Bennett
you [ __ ] up to let's either have a set
[Music]
you
savages of debt Jeremy Sweeney who loves
you [ __ ] a judo connection BB
Tyler J Holden Casper Rockwall Gregory
lay empty Jason snarks and CRF slugline
I love you [ __ ]
thank you for always tweaked and [ __ ]
sending me make it pictures of the
[ __ ] state your sanity [ __ ]
this special is your first version yeah
for special I'm gonna take it a get put
together I mean I've been wanting to
unload this hour for a long time okay so
you had this out for a long yeah but
then like nowhere would take it you know
I get I think you know you're a guy
who's like funny and sometimes hasn't
been not given a chance yeah so same
thing with me you know I've had this uh
I was submitting to the half hour at The
Comedy Central for a long time
year after year no and then I mean in my
mind I was like I don't have credits
maybe that's why I'm not getting it I
might be funny but I don't have these
other credits the people didn't tape a
CD or even I guess not I should have in
hindsight I'm really kicking myself for
not putting on CDs I should have done
that that's hindsight but you know that
I was getting the half from Comedy
Central and then the last year that I
submitted it was like two years ago in
New Mexico filming the Tina Fey movie
whiskey-tango-foxtrot I had done Seth
Meyers and then I was on guy code I had
some credit add some dope credits and I
submitted I thought I'd get it this year
finally and then they said no and I'm
like this is a fool errand I'm done with
this I can't keep yeah yeah yeah yeah if
with these credits in this half-hour
it's they're not giving it to me I'm
never gonna get it I'm done playing this
game and I was so deep in the comedy
game I had an Al where I wanted to
unload not 20 minutes you know with
commercials and everything it's 20
minutes let me try to do an hour so I'm
trying to get an hour and everywhere
saying no but they don't even know what
the hour is they're just saying no to
the idea of me doing you they don't know
what it is so in my mind I'm like let me
tape this thing although I was doing the
headlining weekend in La Jolla so I had
some buddies bring some cameras got some
good audio I cut together an hour of
what it would be we
that around because that if someone says
no to that cool then you just don't [ __ ]
with it but people liked it you know I
think Showtime want to do it but they
were backlogged with their specials and
then and then Cecil was into it so Cecil
was a good home like they liked the
special and so they did it but just one
of those things where you got to cut
their steak for them
you've got it you've got to do it yeah
you really do people don't have people
don't have time or they don't have
imagination with a great agent
oh yeah and people still and it's always
gonna be that way just because you have
a certain name on the door doesn't mean
it's a slam dunk
like you're always gonna be looked over
by somebody so you either just accept
that and cower or you find a window to
get in so I was like let me let me let
me do this [ __ ] show them what it is and
and then that's when the ball got
rolling like there's there's a lot of
people who talk in this town and there's
very few who who actually generate and
create content and when you put it in
front of their face click on this link
here's an hour of stand-up do you like
this then do it cuz most people would be
like hey ask them if they'll let me do
an hour and they go they don't want to
oh man I taped it show them what it is
do a proof of concept do a sizzle so
that's what I did and that's how I got
are we smart yeah you got it or you do
nothing you know I was telling you when
you came in here then when I got in
there was no stand-up for uncle Joey and
I shot a pilot mm-hmm then the power
didn't get picked up you know and then
it's a commercial which was lucrative
yeah it was money but nobody nobody saw
the [ __ ] thing I mean I played
constantly yeah I was in there fart like
it was like a second shop I didn't give
a [ __ ]
good night you gotta check it was like
robbing somebody was embarrassing but
and then I thought it I booked like four
episodes on NBC over popular sitcom and
then they cancelled it right before I
did the first episode like I did episode
like five seven nine and ten they
canceled episode four like I was done
like I didn't get a [ __ ] shot for
Christ's sake you know and it was it was
kind of Costa aureus I kept booking
called stars called stars co-stars one
line yeah one line one line it was like
a [ __ ] curse the curse on the one
line then I got the current then I
finally got four days on a movie seven
days yeah I was like okay now one cuz
I'm gonna guess and then it died again
it died again
then I got that I went through the phase
my line was at the beginning of the
episode phase with credits still rolling
so if you watched taxi I know like [ __ ]
it eight movies is out and that the line
the credits uh-huh analyze that I got
shot first year in the movie taxi I
[ __ ] the first scene in the movie I
got like three or four those
[ __ ] I'm like god damn when
does this end you know I'm almost not
gonna break that my friend the money
he's like they're remaking The Longest
Yard like all made like I gotta call him
and if that time had three three ethical
agents because it was still it wasn't
computer-generated yeah say would they
still mail packages in you live it
through I had three agents who ever got
the job that's who got the Commission
I don't play game yeah I mean one night
I had a showcase at the improv all of
them came out all three Josh was like I
mean agents do you have here I go listen
they'll know about each other it's like
the same things girls some comic will
have three go show a girl's going yeah
they know about each other Penn oh I
called all three of them one guy finally
goes to me the weakest out of all the
three said to me they don't want to see
you they're looking for a name or
celebrity and it burned at me for like
two weeks my said exactly we did yeah I
went to Play It Again Sports and I
bought a football jersey and some
shoulder pads and a helmet for a kid and
I put it on and it looks even bigger
than what I was and I had them throw the
ball at me and I recited the lines from
the old long shot and I got the meeting
and I got it
yeah do you know I didn't learn American
gangster I did it for something else the
one with the bank and I booked that but
then they cut the scene out and talked I
was booking [ __ ] from it booked American
Gangster the first time then they hired
they got rid of the other cow but not
only a lot of the copy of the Spanish do
it at the time that was supposed to play
in the lead the guy that won the Academy
Award for traffic ah the initial
diminution of Thor was the original cop
and in American Gangster then the budget
thing didn't come through so they hired
Cameron Crowe but I booked that me from
[ __ ] tape where they were like nah
they don't want to see you watch my
smoke [ __ ] sometimes you gotta show it
too sometimes you really have to show it
yeah sometimes they lack the imagination
like no just let me show you what it'll
be show you what all you say no what was
the switch in your head or was it just
is that just how you guys were born that
you can say that something more like it
you can know like all right I haven't
been getting it this way let's try
something like was it four years here
was it three years here or is that just
how you guys are this is how how I am
like I know where I want to be where I
know what I want I'll try to go the
traditional route what you're supposed
to do if I hit a wall what's another way
to get there and just keep on doing that
until you break through I thought about
it this way I thought about it that the
worst thing they could say to you was no
yeah okay we're here already
what the [ __ ] and you know you sit here
sometimes and you could sit there and
beat yourself up and go why is it so
easy for him mm-hmm and I gotta break my
balls God has a plan for everybody so I
took it that way and I don't want it I
don't mind for certain things like if
I'm calling you for a weekend and you
ask me for a date I pay this up my mom
Vic all right right off suck my dick guy
I'm a Comedy Store regular right what
the [ __ ] you got there this weekend I'm
like Al Pacino in the in Carlito's Way
[ __ ] do you know I'm not what connected
dude made dudes who have you allowing
purse-snatching Monaco mother
it's a true you know what comedy still
guys I got it for a while there people
say I want to take I'm not selling I'm a
comedies book come see me at the store
at 11:45 ball morning you decide [ __ ]
so that got me insulted but with the
acting I knew there was a big pool to
draw from you know at the time it was
big [ __ ] there was a lot of guys in my
category that through me but I knew they
weren't come see that's what my
confidence game right I know they
couldn't do what I do at 12:45 I got
this book I could do what they could do
but they can't do what I can do what
economists about 12:45
they can't page [ __ ] their pants you
were speaking earlier about acting
classes are their acting classes just
made for comedians like it seems weird
that you guys are going to acting
classes for actors there was a guy in
Tyre when I got here he was supposed to
be the guy that turned comics into
actors so the improv you know this is
1998 The Improv had him there on Mondays
from 11:00 to 3:00 teaching a class I
was like 60 [ __ ] bucks
it was 240 a month you know I think I
went to two classes and it just wasn't
for me I saw a lot more ego than
anything else like he just wasn't - I
got to taste him the best dude ever has
an acting coach was a black dude in
charge twenty bucks an hour
n'gou or he had a hates yeah aids he
says how I was so chief no he never he
had a little school if you go on Gower
between Hollywood Boulevard and sunset
on the same size as Roscoe's chicken
they used to be all those little Hut's
thousands of little huts you get a
little acting class in there the acting
class was mainly at that time $100 a
month yeah but he charge you 20 bucks
that guy got me all the way to the end
I thought Travolta movie it was between
me and Billy Gardell
but they liked us so much that they
thought about just putting me and Billy
Gardell
I said you don't want man in reality
there was two stand-up comics with this
singer we cut it down to one but we'll
bring it back and then Travolta decided
to do the Scientology movie the healthy
allure yes yeah he was going to play
Jimmy Roselli about an Italian singer I
kind of want to see this movie instead
of Battlefield Earth Oh Battlefield
Earth was a [ __ ] disaster this would
have been pretty good
I think Travolta would have pulled it
off this was a long time ago
this is 1999 and Billy Gardell had
already done a lot of TV work maybe and
they came to see it's at the store they
came to a Laugh Factory to see me and
the [ __ ] store to see me and then I
went to Miami and problem was I'm Miami
I asked Mike all my magic goes I got bad
news for you they pulled the plug on the
movie
what do you mean they asked Jesus Christ
you know read as easy was here last week
calling years ago I live under him
coming out here first and there was a
string he was going on that you would
kill yourself most actors would have
killed himself I think he went for like
eleven [ __ ] I mean he was ready to
kill himself
and then the leak I said to him every
time you go you get a little closer
you're gonna get it you're right there
it's just a [ __ ] hair away from the
availment looking the man the [ __ ]
lead yeah you know once you start
getting all those cold eyes missing them
eases something around the corner that's
what I would do totally and even if you
don't get it there's the people in
positions of power have a familiarity
about you you're not this dark horse
anymore and like I know this guy know
what he's about and they have you in
mind for something so it's less of a
reach the third or fourth time I uh my
goal when I used to have acting
notebooks like I would have a a chart in
the beginning like let's say you opened
up my notebook I'd have like this and
then let's say tomorrow or b-36 I would
have like three six and then it would be
a chart that would go down and it would
have like the name of the project
I'd have to cast the director and then I
have the role I was going out for I'm
gonna have like boxes like if I went to
the first like if it was TV in those
days it was always two callbacks and
then you booked it for film it was
always one some on big movies when I
first got hit with pre reads
yeah little dollar something like those
where you read with the assistant then
you come back and read for the casting
director then you come back again and I
had planned that bran would look at the
sides and I would go okay I'm gonna read
this three times so I'm gonna put
together work each time is gonna be
stronger than the other before I even go
into the audition like I would [ __ ]
bro I got into it I got into it like I
was like I'm gonna have this audition
for this this one for the callback and
this rule for producers they're all in
the same neighborhood but I'm gonna do
something different for each one just to
show him I'm ahead of the game well I
would [ __ ] him up probably it would take
one time I ripped down under where's his
audition it called for a fibro pilots
I'll shoot a [ __ ] because pilots
in the old days used to be a pretty
decent [ __ ] paid that I want it for
American family laughs this one they was
out different about ten years ago I came
up and it called for a fat guy to be out
this long like this like a story about
you you you leave your family's house
and move into you you move into your
first house but as you're walking in you
hear some guy go hey it's beautiful out
here that's a dude like me with short
time you know in a kiddie pool frying
like a hamburger hold a barbecue but to
him this is heaven I'm saying his wife
is a beast of birth and his kids were
all [ __ ] diabetic and he's out there
and I never feel like a what if I was in
there with a pair of like red white and
blue on the way I like to be cut and I
knew who was going like in those days I
had a crew Italian guys that would call
me the night before and they'd say oh
you can't win it for that role yeah so I
knew how it was going up against there
was this dude that God having missed so
God rest his soul his thing was
something Tony something he was in
Phoebus in the movie splash with Tom
Hanks in John Candy he'd been around
here a while he was killing me dog
I got auditions he'd kill me kill me so
I had to figure out how to get this guy
on [ __ ] check so I thought about that
audition he called me right before his
I'm going for it I know if he cashed the
directors she put me in something else I
said ah this [ __ ] trying to
piss on my leg and crack me up I went to
the store in this one I went to Kmart or
wherever I bought myself some red white
and blue [ __ ] bikini shorts
I put sweats over it I took a
wife-beater
that showed my stomach a little bit and
I pulled it up I scotch scotch tape and
I put a little wife beater and I got a
warm-up jacket like with a zipper so you
couldn't tell what I have underneath and
I'm like Joey if you do this you will
book this [ __ ] job because I used to
book on psychological purposes
like outgoing then listen to what you're
saying and I'll do opposite like I'm
gonna listen to what Lee said you said
the other kind I don't do opposite you
guys are all on the wrong thing you're
all doing the same thing yeah we gotta
go in there something different oh I
never forget I walked in there and
they're like hi mr. Diaz give us a
second perfect that they turn their back
to me and as they turn their back to me
I took that [ __ ] oh that sweatshirt
off with my little wife beaters when I
was 375 this is a different game I'm 297
dollars this is 375 with Thai red wine
Church with white the [ __ ] cocaine
legs I took those sweatpants off and
when they turned around they went so
they just froze and I didn't even say
action I just said hey you want a burger
living like a doctor ha ha ha ha ha ha
and they just looked at me and they said
can you turn on tape real quick I knew I
had him I had him on the ropes I did it
on tape bruh before I got home that made
an offer and everything that rule went
down there for nothing that's what I'm
the time I went to the audition door
gonna had a hole in my pants
for if you watch it people still hit me
up and go are you an extra and what's
that stupid [ __ ] show How I Met Your
Mother
yeah I went into the audition I had no
underwear on I when I went to sit down
the hole in the pants got caught in the
chair in the leg of the chair like the
arm thing yeah and it ripped open and my
balls came out I sat down there was
three landing produces I go did you see
the Cuban that grow and they just looked
at the dog and started I went and throw
them with them what happened why I
forgot to wear underwear I just told the
whole story all right deal and you're
good I booked it and then they my agent
calls me go go back you didn't even read
oh yeah I wasn't there for 30 minutes
just laughing about the hole in my
shorts inning read I went back read they
booked a nice tank at the How I Met Your
Mother like we didn't want you had no
choice yeah I [ __ ] them up so [ __ ]
bad with my pants opened up as I just
played along with it what the [ __ ]
it's amazing how the world is very
different like if you went into a
meeting at Boeing and like tried to like
well Ivan up the room a little
god oh my god yeah I have to the exact
opposite so you would never really even
might rather have a sense of humor then
I mean I would amongst my co-workers and
stuff but I mean you can't do that in uh
in like a meeting with people and stuff
it's very corporate and drive I'm crazy
don't work and live that way yeah that's
why you got out I'd rather shoot myself
I always wanted to do comedy it was
always just sort of biding my time until
I could make the leap so it's not like I
I was just cog in the wheel and then I
had an epiphany like I gotta get out
that's a romanticized version who's just
all very calculated and premeditated
like alright just keep doing this [ __ ]
until you put yourself into position to
make the leap and so I mean it was fine
you have the worst jobs but obviously
this is way doper then but one of my
favorite sayings is take a chance
Columbus did yeah that's it that's it
and I felt like you can chase money
whenever that's always there you can
always chase money what what we're doing
there's there's a window there's a
window to do it how old you when you
made this decision maybe I was like 26
pushes yeah Bush well how people don't
know that money ain't thick yeah money
ain't thick you don't you know when
you're young all you want is money they
press those girls and I know subscribe
to that though which is no I did I did
for a while you know eyes I think I'm a
suck your dick well no matter what you
know saying well you show up with a
Corvette at Cosby Pitt also be sniffing
your ballsack
there's something very alluring about
somebody who who doesn't subscribe to
that white picket fence and cars and
there are plenty of girls who like
rockers who don't make any money or like
comics who are there's something sexy
about somebody who's just going after
that and isn't getting the the house and
the cars and all that stuff cuz then
that's there's not a lot of people doing
that and they feel like no you're tapped
into something that I need those things
but this person doesn't it kills me
where I came to an age one day well I
think yeah about 30 when I said you know
what this money shouldn't even worth it
they even worth it for years I kept
trying to chase it cuz I don't ever
change my life but did
I was still the same person I was and it
wasn't I changed my game up and looked
at it you know when you get into comedy
when you when you first been at the
comedy unless you you know you were very
smart you had a day job you know that
they jump from one till one day you go
I'm not doing this no more taking a
[ __ ] chance that's it you know it's
hard we talked about putting things into
universe how how many times I had a job
the last month so as we get on a month
to pay rent I can't tell you how many
times that happened but it didn't have
you know you'll make times I went to the
store I'm like a Tuesday nights I didn't
want to go down there and somebody would
come up to me he goes dog and canceling
Kansas City this week you want it think
I say that you could do it if you wanted
you know like I wasn't even I come down
here tonight there were six people
because in those days you would call and
go how's the room you never go there's
like 30 people we don't want to come
down here we have enough people when you
get lazy I was down there three nights
in a row you realize that just leaving
the house is a big part of the
opportunities come just by leaving your
apartment
sometimes you can get discouraged early
on and stand up and you're like I'm not
getting spots and I have no spot tonight
why am I gonna hang out but like that
happens some of the hey can you do this
out of sight out of mind so it even just
pays just being around you know it's the
hustle that it takes to do this at this
level it's amazing and I love when
people miscalculated I like when
somebody thinks they have the [ __ ]
answer you know they don't know that I
get up at 6:00 and I tweet and I [ __ ]
do this am i right and then no [ __ ]
idea what you're dan yeah how much work
then at 10 o'clock you call your agent
then you call your manager then you have
to check with your [ __ ] emails I'm
starting to get scripts from [ __ ]
these podcasts and advertisers and you
know your day is gone and you're like
you know and then now I still got two
[ __ ] spots and that entails
driving and valet parking and going in
there taking your mind it never [ __ ]
ends but why are you here why you young
you know being young means you're a
[ __ ] slave [ __ ] that's what it meant
in my world when I was you know so 40 it
meant forget about it you're 20 it's
like if I had a normal
like yours in my 20s I'd be working
getting my dick sucked on Fridays and
Saturdays point-blank that's it
I'm living to get my money when I was 20
I was living again I but there were kids
that have great jobs that would live it
and get that dick so that's it that's
all that was on luckily I had tunnel
vision this is all I wanted so I didn't
I wasn't partying I wasn't drinking and
it was just work comedy because I knew
any I used to play video games a lot and
I just stopped doing video good for you
yeah yeah it's amazing when you get to
the next level of what you want the
things that you have to sacrifice yeah
just that most people will never never
ever [ __ ] grasp that they'll never
grasp at and they'll sit and make
excuses and tell you how you gay
somebody sucked your dick in Hollywood
you know what hey you know when you
first start doing comm you start going
to these D rooms
yeah totally you'll often I'll pass out
that there's just a lot of towns that
have like B room C rooms and you start
working with these frustrated headliners
it's a real education like I always tell
people you got to do a couple triple
runs to work with guys that are in
Seattle that are doing a triple run and
have a thousand stories and I'll tell
you why they'll never move to LA you
know and there's people who don't write
long move to LA because the Seattle
SuperSonics were yelling work and the
Seattle Mariners are giving work and the
[ __ ] football team was giving him
work and he had four kids or two kids
and a wife but there was other people
from uptight I just didn't want to do
that and I don't have time for that [ __ ]
like this is something that you keep
moving I never thought like did you
really you came down here to stand them
did you think there was any opportunity
of movies a TV yeah cuz I know that a
lot of actors and stuff they came from
stand-up I wasn't the type to just
abandon stand-up if that were to happen
but I knew that cuz I love I like acting
and things I like writing I like I like
doing that I never thought I would book
anything really
I always thought that was a possibility
but I just knew that stand-up was my way
into that or that would happen as a
result of it I thought I would be an
extra if
lucky really I don't know I just look at
you and you just like there's not a lot
of people like you so I would think that
you'd book all the time and you and you
have in your mind you think I'm not
going to but sometimes you'll see people
in Hollywood you like all this guy's
such a type he's gonna work all the time
I don't think that's telling me half as
much I didn't write that well maybe
because you got some other plate
spinning into you that is you gotta
stand up yeah they're special I know the
down and stuff like that but it's uh I
take the biggest part for me of going
back to the comedy store it's seen guys
like you and me and guys like you I
never thought about this part of my life
you know I went back first row up to
seven years and there was all new faces
I mean it was all new faces it was very
cool to see guys like you and Rogan come
back who were such a part of the store
but not when I was there I would only
hear stories so it's very cool to see
you guys come back into the fold and
some other guys as well yeah I love it
would run White's down there and shop
now I mean it's just but it's really
helped me to see you young guys like I
didn't know this is what it became I
didn't when I first got to restore the
older guys were scumbags they were the
leftovers of the Kennison days yeah
then nobody talked to and they were like
to always have a story they were
scumbags I mean I don't know how many
times had arguments and all the
character comment and that's why when I
went back I made myself promising
someone I wouldn't linger down there I
feel like a pedophile even saying like
I'm a [ __ ] old benefice out there
talking for the waitress is his [ __ ] I
wasn't gonna drink down and I wasn't
done that once I did my set I had to get
out of there because of the impression
that those other old time is left on me
they were the biggest [ __ ] pukes and
I'd love to say their [ __ ] names but
they live in their own misery now cuz
they're not even up that no one who's
was still in the game yeah there was
some old guys up there that were just
miserable and they would watch you get
off stage and like wish bad like you
could see if there was a handful of guys
that would go up there every [ __ ]
night for fallouts
and rule against you Ruettiger
you won't against you when you got off
stage they'd say hey tougher audience
like they'd be like five of them sitting
by the paint where the payphone used to
be like they weren't really watching but
we're like if you have a good set they
ones they make believe like they didn't
watch how'd it go in there but if you
bombed they let you know they let you
know it rough night tonight huh and you
will look at them and go like I could
[ __ ] yous up right now but I feel bad
for you I feel bad that you're at this
part of your life and you a chili
against chameleons yeah it's hard and
you know how hard our job is so that
makes no sense to me when like they're
your peer you should have a love for
your peers they just want everyone to do
well like if your friend does well it
helps you out I really go down there
with a different mindset when I go down
to the store I really try to not let my
I need to be a certain person I go to
the store now you know I need to act
like an adult
Shelagh saying like it's real important
to me to act like an adult and help you
guys have like any question you man I
don't never come up to you I have a tag
that's enough of my business get the
[ __ ] away from me with your [ __ ] tag
you creepy [ __ ] tag you know I don't
know I don't even have a tag for myself
don't give me no tags worried by
yourself I'm not that type of dude but
I'm there just to say hey man that was
tremendous or because some nights I knew
when I was alone for a rough night but
there was one cool person who came up to
me said hey man that was a great yeah I
feel like god damn it thank you bro and
that night you go home and you go you
know I shouldn't treat all the people at
the straw that there's still a couple of
great souls I sometimes I think I'm
dying and I get off in the photographer
who is the bassist guy in the world I
come up to me and go that joke about
your boss you're the nicest guy in the
world them you know Troy Troy Khan yeah
well I mean he's just a great guy this
this time thing you leave there you're
like I'm not even gonna bond it's so bad
he'll come up to you know that was a
good job man that was a good good job at
least Jon in there and you're like you
know man
please and all those old it was a
[ __ ] ugly scene like from from my 97
to about 2000 like I was dead a weekend
some of the old deeds in the back like
that's a pledge this store was these
guys were getting there at 7:00 and they
were drinking and they were shooting
heroin in the back oh the guy OD please
back in Nashville some ways that
somebody like can I respond what was
that was another comic like can I have
this photo these guys will go up to sign
up for the fallout list uh-huh and wait
not together doing those days early you
got there you'd be number one on the
fallout list unless Mitch he came in and
then Mitzi we go right at least I am
down your number ten and you will
[ __ ] die like that would that you
just face this we got time to do the
first fallout you know Joey Diaz loves
to cancel and all submits he comes in
and bump [ __ ] you like but there were
always losses and they would cheer
against him then there was this other
guys that were leftovers from the
Kenaston days and they would go down
there at night you know what their woes
and they're showing on camera this week
you know like they were still talking
about Kennison and all that [ __ ] then
that was just a bunch of other guys down
there that would just hate like that
thought all those guys hated dice like
what dice for coming those nights to
bump but I never hated like dice was
bumping me and I didn't have a chip from
Eddie Griffin was bumping me like
airtight you know this to get past and
if they get a spot on Monday night at
10:30 and for Kenny Griffin to come up
to you right before you're gonna go on
stays and ups he did that to me I had
the house full I brought 20 of my best
friends from Seattle it's opening like
the commies thought Eddie Griffin bump
smack that I hate them and no hatred
towards him it was all in education and
sometimes you have to pay respect to the
guys of the rough day you know I'm happy
they don't bump it to store that right I
mean it happens sometimes but I get it I
get it too like well I don't give a [ __ ]
if they Chanel walks in he's tremendum
item going him up put up running white
put up [ __ ] Adam Sandler put up
Saracen when they pay that [ __ ] dudes
you know I would never ask the monthly
money it would be outside of my round
bro if you notice when I get the light I
get all yeah
I don't disrespect so don't ever [ __ ]
disrespect me and we'll never have a
mother looking problem that's why I do
that my respect comics with the utmost
[ __ ] I was thinking about a weird
story the other day I used to open like
he was talking about hosting uh-huh I
used to host all the time on Sundays I
used to host and work the door for 25
bucks
that's how much Mitzi would like that
worked the back door and then go host at
the same time why I never figured I told
this kid just the microphone was broke
on a Sunday night there was like 60
people in there and I said before he
went on stage that to call the open mic
is you know you have that list I go do
me a favor
don't touch the microphone and there was
this one kid that I told my 10 times
don't walk way to this [ __ ] what
happened didn't I feel like if you broke
- he broke it there was no microphone
the rest of it I go got a microphone
from the [ __ ] belly room it didn't
work and I kept sizzling and that
[ __ ] came out I said something I
got his [ __ ] face because he
disrespected all of us man well I did
that they know we just told you not to
touch the [ __ ] microphone you know we
gotta go to La Jolla one weekend he kept
calling the store they used to beat me
up his buddies they still got the pool
hall ahoy and there's a little pool
table none I used to have a pool table I
took all the balls out of it and I
strategically put them in the flower
pots outside I had them in my pockets I
took all the cue balls Chuck Norris
style and Steven Seagal but one about
Brooklyn was thinking about who shot
Bobby Lupo
I hit sticks I had pipes I went behind
the barn I got a knife I think I know
why they took the pool table they took
their blood I hid everything bro and
these dumb frogs got together and they I
saw the car at the top of La Jolla and
I've been from the counters door and
they're right there they're gonna make a
left and they man I'm behind the door
I'm waiting for him to come down I'm
making believe like I'm smoking a
cigarette I don't see him they come
around the turn they come shooting down
and has that kind of pulling [ __ ]
water gun out like those big spray guns
I take the [ __ ] cue ball and I just
whip it at him and it hits the side door
he goes boom they thought a missile hit
him they didn't get a shot to shoot me
with the water pistol
they took off and called Hollywood
Comedy Store and said Joey Diaz broke
you boil Alice's [ __ ] this war when I
like three years with me and these two
world kids I'll even do comment on what
it's like 15 years ago he said so the
special comes that one Thursday this
there's Thursday you excited brother I
am man I'm very happy with it like the
way it looks and in the material where'd
you shoot it
Alex Theatre and Glendale good for you
yeah just kept it in town I didn't want
it's nice being able to wake up and just
drive to the gig not hop on a plane you
know it's your own special and to do it
in LA I know how the jokes do here I did
the road too but it's like home court I
wanted to do it here I'll do it here
roll with that man yeah and are you
excited very excited I will talk to back
up this PR stuff I'm gonna go to New
York at the end of March to promote that
and then when the crapshoot festival and
in May I've made light beam through 21st
yeah yeah yeah yeah in Vegas
no thank you what hotel I don't know
what hotel it I got a look at the thing
but it's a nice little festival they got
they got some cool people coming out who
offices in a way almost the guy I got
man I forget it's like a Morgan Murphy
you know the time shoot yeah clap shoot
Adam ray Brad Brad Williams trying to
think who else I think Beth Stelling is
doing it too I think Ian might be doing
it I don't know good for you man yeah
like I said murder there Oh crisis
they're cool David tell no longer a lot
of people there Josh Anna Meyers is
there just Trey how another oh [ __ ]
yeah he's doing well he won the he's
hosting tonight yeah so that'll be fun
but you did your son see so right yes
out there it's still out there I really
enjoyed where do you shoot yours
Chicago at the zany's out in Rosemont
a pendant like this downtown one I want
to shoot those a nice roast
so I think it was a great idea going to
see so I think you made a good choice
yeah they let me do whatever there is
never any editing but let me do whatever
I wanted to it came out how I wanted
they've been really supportive and
everything um I wanted to be a big fish
on a small island you know like I wanted
to really like it stick out a little bit
you can get lost it like yeah Agnes's
cool and everything but I'll get lost it
was fine I don't think I should pal with
- oh yeah
and I thought that seesaw was supported
like you said I took that data and they
were really into it like yeah they're
worried I could have done Netflix if I
just really hounded and like fought and
scrapped but Cecil is just so into it I
was like yeah I think it's a good choice
I wish you I mean bro you want a bright
lights at the store thank you so much I
was today with a character Lance Lance
against awfully its Gestapo
more to you but he's a loose cannon he's
everything that I wish I could be man
you know he just goes up there in a wife
beater and a mullet and just he's kind
of like you man and just takes the
audience by the horns and just whatever
happens happens
cuz I'm kind of heady I have bits of
[ __ ] that I'm trying to work out Lance
just shows up and whatever happens
happens and in some time that's great I
knew you would doing someone crazy one
they're like what the [ __ ] eat don't
what is that long hair to it and it's
something that the Comedy Store comics
really like and like it seems like it's
almost sort of similar to you Joey where
you're not like a hidden secret but like
something like a favorite of everyone
who's there every night because every
time I'm there cuz every time you go up
something different happens like you're
not gonna get the same Joey di set every
time you go up and I think doing Lance
is kind of like my version of that just
the it's never the same and there's
something fresh each time because I
think that's why people like it and they
resonate look good for you I mean listen
like I said you wouldn't be here if I
didn't my I want people if you supported
me man do me a favor download is special
on Thursday yeah he's funny he's a
[ __ ] sweetheart give him the code yet
so it's a free month if you typed my
last name for the promo code give me the
[ __ ] last name and you are a and w AR
every month say it again the last name
Anwar a
and w AR so write that down
do me a favor write that down anw AR go
to see so right now type in another
[ __ ] month for free so the month that
you had with me must be ending - this is
December 8th January 8th that's it you
out there you can't watch sign that live
I'm giving you another month opportunity
to help out my brother here watch his
special he's funny as [ __ ] I think he's
one of the bright lights at the store
and I think he'll love them I wouldn't
have money just to have money he's a
solid [ __ ] and he's with me he's
with me and he's one of us that's it
thank you as a small he's he's a decent
kid unlikely syat that's a [ __ ]
healing dispenser of reefer and edibles
and shoe cubes and all that other [ __ ]
and you have Chinese heroin Chinese hair
that's so that's not what I'm the year
this year I got a batch coming fresh
from Toronto so number two we won't
shoot it unless you want them I think we
should shoot it I don't want to shoot it
at all what he talking about I think we
should get a nurse to come in here with
IVs ah and [ __ ] shoot his dad
number one blue apron is the number one
fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country I hope you know
that like we always talk about Lee his
dad I've had it I love it I just like my
wife cooks my wife likes to cook so I
let it cook I cook for the baby you know
there's no blue apron for the baby so
that's the only reason why I don't get
it but if not I'd be living off that
family it's and I'd eat the whole thing
by myself if I was a bachelor I'd be
getting the family [ __ ] a meal every
week by myself three four dishes I'd be
a cure and every [ __ ] chef of that
the understand me blue apron has
established partnerships in over 150
local farms fisheries and ranchers
across the United States as a result the
seafood is sustained Lee under standards
developed in partnership partnership
with the Monterey Bay Aquarium Seafood
Watch beef chicken and pork come from
responsible raised animals and the
produce is sourced from farms that
practice regenerative farming those who
spend a lot at restaurants or at
high-end grocery chains can now spend on
the ten dollars per person on the
delicious
meal cooking Tibet together build strong
family bonds the research shows that
blue apron families cook nearly three
times more often alright
featured upcoming meals I got salmon
piccata with orzo and broccoli I got
pork chops with miso butter bok choy and
marinated apples
I got vegetable chili baked sweet
potatoes with crispy tortilla chips are
you kidding me or what and here you go
spicy shrimp coconut curry with cabbage
and rice you know how to make that by
yourself you don't have a goddamn clue
let blue a from help you this is we're
gonna do it right so less than ten
dollars boy up and deliver seasonal
recipes along with people portion
ingredients to make delicious
home-cooked meals you're gonna choose
variety of recipes new week or like blue
aprons culinary teen surprise you
recipes will not be repeated for a year
so let's pretend you don't get the spicy
shrimp coconut Carey with the cabbage
and rice you are gonna eat it for a year
and you're gonna learn how to cook it
each meal comes with a step-by-step easy
to follow a recipe card and proportion
ingredients that can be prepared than 40
minutes or less guaranteed blue apron
all fresh this guarantee promises that
every ingredient your delivery arrives
ready to cook or they'll make it right
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals with Free Shipping
with Free Shipping with Free Shipping by
going to blue apron comm slash Joey
again you'll love how it feels
taste and to create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron so
don't wait go to blue apron comm slash
Joey again blue apron calm slash Joey
listen you're sitting there scratching
your ass you're waiting for this job to
call you you can't figure out what
you're gonna do you sent out resumes I
got the answer lift it's that easy okay
every time I ride with a lift I get
there safe on time the drivers courteous
the cars are clean they don't smell like
ass and it's a dependable ride I like to
tell you about a smart way to earn money
and get an extra $500 bonus
driving with
you're in between jobs looking at a
little extra looking to put money
together for your kids college fund
you're going back to school and you want
another degree or you want to get your
first one or you're writing the first
your next great American novel and
you're looking for inspiration alright
lyft drivers could make up to 35 miles
an hour and getting started it's just a
tap away
you can drive mornings nights weekends
just flip in the driver mode and start
making doremi aka money plus lyft
drivers current tips right through the
app and those tips have it fast and you
don't have to wait days or weeks to get
paid you can cash out instantly once
you've made 50 dollars thanks to Express
pay driving with lyft is super flexible
allows you to keep 100% of your tips and
it's always there when you need extra
cash do me a favor again you just
sitting there scratching your ass
take a shot Columbus did like my man
Fahim sign up today at live.com slash
Joey again lift calm slash Joey and for
right now lyft has a special offer for
our listeners you'll get a $500 new
driver bonus after you complete a
hundred rides in 30 days you could do
that standing on your head go to lift
calm slash Joey today and start making
money and get you a five-run allow a new
driver bonus limited time only
restrictions apply I want to thank lift
I want to thank blue apron I also want
to thank alikom always sending me the
best with shroom tack or the hemp
protein powder go to Holland calm and
press in church BAM CH you are CH and
get 10% off your first order delivered
straight the Alps listen Thursday first
thing you do for me and I'm gonna remind
you Wednesday night is to go to see
short calm and press in Anwar BAM and
get a month of free on the [ __ ] arm
like I don't ask you people for nothing
do me a favor watch this kids special I
love it we'll be back Wednesday night
[ __ ] tremendous podcast I love
you guys have a great week stay black
and remember if they don't like what you
dream is tell them to suck your dick
it's over
[Music]